con 61 votos a favor 47 en contra y 5
abstenciones la presidenta del congreso
de perú lady camones fue destituida del
cargo porque el pleno del parlamento
concluyó que estaba comprometida en
presuntos delitos de suspensión de
funciones patrocinio ilegal y tráfico de
influencias la remoción de camiones se
produce luego de la difusión de unos
audios donde se escucha al líder
político césar acuña pedir a leidy
camones y otros congresistas de alianza
para el progreso que agilice en la
aprobación de una ley para la creación
de un distrito esta gestión favorecería
a césar acuña en su postulación a
gobernador de la región la libertad en
las elecciones que se realizan en perú
el próximo 2 de octubre algunos
legisladores como el derechista el bis
vergara consideran que la destitución de
camón es perjudica la imagen del
parlamento pero era necesaria ahora el
congreso peruano que en manos de la
fujimorista martha moyano que en cinco
días convocar a elecciones para que los
parlamentarios elijan a un nuevo
presidente o presidenta del poder
legislativo por su parte los asesores
legales del presidente pedro castillo
presentaron una denuncia contra lady
camones césar acuña y algunos
congresistas por organización criminal
debido a que un audio se oye que los
denunciados acuerdan adherirse a una
moción de vacancia presidencial que se
presentará en el parlamento contra el
mandatario peruano los aliados de pedro
castillo piden a la fiscalía la
detención preliminar de los
comprometidos en la conspiración así
como el allanamiento de sus domicilios y
oficinas